[Music]
real estate really really matters it's
the biggest
financial and emotional decision that
the average person will make
real estate's the largest segment of the
global economy and
nobody loves it for many people it's
hard to wrap their head around by taking
this class
i'm gonna demystify the entire process
for you
i founded a real estate technology
platform
its sole mission is to make real estate
better for
everyone there are a lot of
misconceptions about the real estate
industry
it's an industry that powers single
parents people like my mom
who from a very early age made me a
dreamer
i saw her as an entrepreneur and it
instilled in me
this desire to create build
dream and be an entrepreneur myself
there's no blueprint
for buying a home but i am going to give
you some general guidelines
of how to approach it so that you can be
successful
[Music]
i'm going to give you an insider tip
when you're in an open house
treat it like a flea market try not to
share your enthusiasm
you want them to see how confident you
are but not that you need this
when you're a seller i highly urge you
if you want to maximize the value of
your home make it move-in ready
homes that are move-in ready sell faster
than homes that don't
being raised with a single parent where
my father passed away when i was young
i've been searching for belonging my
entire life
i'm black and jewish so i never felt
like i really belonged
in any category part of the dream
was i was going to create a family and
this family would be great
but it all comes down to that home a
home
is the culmination of that belonging
concrete stability security memories
it's your place in the world
at the end of this class i want you to
feel like you could dream bigger
that anything is possible opportunity is
everywhere around you
i'm robert repkin and this is my
master class
[Music]
you